j'suis à lévis au centre des congrès
vendredi soir c'est ici que ça se passe
pour le choix du futur chef du parti
québécois avec plus de 700 personnes
des pics est de québec n'était pas
content de devoir traverser l'autre bord
du fleuve parce qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'événements officiels organisés par le
parti québécois on nous dit que c'est
pour des raisons logistiques de coups
notamment mais on le voit bien c'est
vraiment une grosse organisation
afin de la soirée y aura un accès
beaucoup de choses beaux films camera
beaucoup de logistique de la soirée va
être différente qu'en 2015 quand pierre
karl péladeau avait été choisie chef
c'est un mode de scrutin différent un
vote préférentiel qui pourrait aller
jusqu'à trois tours et à chaque tour on
élimine un candidat
les résultats vont être présentés en
rafale vers 21h soirée différente que
l'année dernière également parce que pkp
l'avait emporté avec une majorité dès le
premier vote cette fois ci il ya une
véritable course qui rend l'issue
imprévisible et qui risque de laisser
des cicatrices véritable défi du
prochain chef sera certainement celui de
rassembler les troupes suivi nous en
soirée on sera là en direct sur facebook